I'm heading from Brooklyn to uptown
Manhattan for what used to be a routine
doctor's appointment the first effective
drug to treat the biggest pandemic in
more than a century they're China's
centric to put it nicer but they're a
puppet of China
it's Friday May 22nd 2020 any year's
quick-take trap of the pandemic this
week you may have noticed in your
neighborhood and across the u.s. many
people are opting out of a routine trip
to the doctor's office during this
pandemic but as my colleague Angelo
shows us that's not always an option for
people with chronic conditions I go
every eight weeks to get an infusion of
a medicine called Remicade it's for
Crohn's disease so I haven't been it's
before the city lockdown so I have no
idea what to expect
[Music]
on a normal day where I come through
here every day to go to work its types
of commuters completely fallen out
basically empty to mana so numb on the
lovely Upper East Side of Manhattan but
you may be familiar with from the hit
television show Gossip Girl hey Upper
East Siders Gossip Girl for sure you'll
notice that my mask is not great it's
actually a balaclava meant for keep you
warm and you're running or riding a bike
and I'm wearing work gloves
I had a surgical mask and I had rubber
gloves but I basically wore them all out
buying groceries over the past couple
weeks
[Music]
they gave me a new mask which is great
and I'm in a private suite normally
these infusions take place in a room
with maybe like three to five people in
them usually older people people who are
getting hooked up to an IV like myself
so it's nice that water in our own space
is here my infusion is for a medicine
for our Crohn's disease which is an
autoimmune disease
for some people it's pretty mild but
myself
I've actually had to have three pieces
of my intestine removed in my lifetime
[Music]
the medicine that I take makes me
immunocompromised basically I just sit
here for two hours well there's medicine
drips into my arm it's not that bad
I'm a guy that plays in Animal Crossing
[Music]
so I'm good for another eight weeks that
I've got my mask and some fresh gloves
it was a little crowded not everyone
even had masks and gloves so I think
I'll take my chances in a car so I
wanted to check in with my
gastroenterologist who only sees
patients with chronic conditions how are
you I'm well thank you for asking have
you guys had patients expressed
hesitancy about coming in people are
afraid to go to hospitals and afraid to
even just resume routine care just like
you had to get used to being at home and
wearing a mask you're gonna have to use
get used to coming outside and doing all
the things that you still need to get
done because that's still part of life
was there one maybe key insight from the
notes from national institutions about
IV knee patients the main question
everybody's mind is that our people are
immuno on immune suppressing medications
in for a very rough ride if they get the
corner virus infection although there
was a sphere of it it turns out that in
fact they were not having worse outcomes
based on this so there was an early
theory that
know that these drugs while they may
increase the risk of getting a viral
infection that they might decrease the
risk of a severe outcome from the rural
infection by interrupting the cytokine
storm that's been this right so in terms
of having worse outcomes than the
general population has not been seen
[Music]
during this global pandemic the world
for the most part has looked to the
World Health Organization for guidance
instead it's found controversy you know
right now they're they're literally a
pipe organ for China that's a way of you
can this crisis forced the world to say
we really do eat a well-functioning and
truly neutral world fell apart that will
not be beholden to various financial
interests this is the story of how the
w-h-o tried to please the world and
ended up losing its biggest backer
[Music]
antiviral drug from death severe has
been giving the world some hope in the
fight against covin 19 here's how the
drug maker Gilead Sciences has been
preparing for this moment on New Year's
Eve of 2019 a scientist at Gilead
Sciences received a disturbing email
from a top virologist there are rare
cases of a mysterious pneumonia going
around in Wuhan China nobody knew what
was causing it
watch this one the biologist warned it
might be a new corona virus Ram des
Avira is one of the few experimental
medicines back in January that had
already shown promise against a wide
variety of corona viruses so when
Chinese scientists confirmed that
mysterious pneumonia was indeed caused
by never-before-seen corona virus a
couple weeks later dee-lighted
scientists knew right away that their
drug was going to be a top candidate to
treat it there haven't been many
examples of foresight preparedness in
this pandemic but the story of Gilead
Mendez aveer is one of them kovita 19
can be characterized as a pandemic at a
time before the World Health
Organization confirmed there was
human-to-human spread the long before
anyone knew was pandemic Gilead started
forming a task force studying how to
test from des vir and if it worked how
to mass-produce it quickly the
months-long process employs 70 raw
materials reagents and catalysts and
they're mostly processed in 25 largely
sequential steps but thanks to the
company's earlier work with room des of
Ebola it already had a small supply of
the drug on hand and that allowed
clinical trials to begin almost right
away in China in Europe and elsewhere
however filling enough vials to treat
potentially millions of patients in the
pandemic would require a lot more of the
drug so back in January gilad ordered
enough of necessary key ingredients to
produce more than a million patient
courses by the end of 2020 that early
decision helped pave the way for what
appears to be the first effective drug
to treat the biggest pandemic
more than a century Brenda Sevilla has a
clear-cut significant positive effect in
diminishing the time to recover Gilead
has reported that one of its coronavirus
drugs is working it's one of the
most-watched therapies on being able to
potentially treat koban 19 but to be
clear it's not a miracle drug in severe
cases of covin 19 the medicine appears
to speed up recovery by about 4 days
according to preliminary results of a
1,000 patient trial the US Food and Drug
Administration didn't allow Gilead to
claim that the drug is safe and
effective Accord 19 it only said there's
a reasonable probability that the dog
may help
Gilead plans to donate the first 1.5
million vials enough for roughly the
first 200,000 patients and says that by
fall a much larger supplies to start to
become available the question is can
Gilead and his partners make enough of
the drug for the whole world
[Music]
ghovat 19 vaccine development and
deployment in China when available will
be made a global public good
[Music]
[Music]
so more and more questions are coming up
about social distancing especially at
States begin to open up and the weather
gets nicer bloomberg news health
reporter Kristen Brown like many of us
has been one of those people asking some
of the questions about social distancing
this has been hard right I live in the
Bay Area we were the first place in the
country to go on lockdown a few weeks in
like everybody you start to get restless
I missed my best friend I missed having
a drink with a friend at a bar I started
asking questions about what is actually
risky behavior and what is not and you
were able to speak to some public health
experts who said that the messaging
needs to change what did they tell you I
think we're really at this inflection
point there was a moment where public
health experts agree it was very
important for us to shelter in place wow
the curve is flattening the risk has it
gone away we don't have a vaccine we
don't have a way to protect people from
getting infected again experts are
calling for us to re-examine what we
have learned about the virus and to then
apply that to social distancing policies
so that we can still have good health
and hygiene practices but also me your
best friend in the park for a beer from
six feet away New York City for example
is really ahead of the game they just
put out guidelines for how to safely
have sex during Cova 19 they present it
not as a binary risk there is a spectrum
of risk the messaging going forward is
gonna be that we really need to look at
the science look at what's going on with
a virus and be nimble what are some of
the things that they told you about
kovin 19 that people can may be used to
assess their own risky behavior we know
for example that the virus is much less
likely to transmit in outdoor areas
having a picnic outdoors with your
friends as long as you're not hugging
and sharing a beer is a lot safer than
having people over for dinner some
public health experts are encouraging
people to go outdoors and some cities
have done that for example Oakland where
I live
we have blocked off 10% of the streets
now to car traffic so that people can
get out enjoy the beautiful California
sunshine what are the things that are
still high risk I think any behavior in
which there's high contact so shaking
hands hugging probably don't invite your
friends over to watch a movie on your
couch until the rate of transmission has
slowed or until there's a vaccine these
really are risky behaviors but you can
still socialize outdoors with your
friends out of safe distance
[Music]
in Ukraine in all-female pink taxi
services saving lives by delivering
dialysis to patients during the lockdown
take a look
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hi everyone I'm Sara Pontic and I am a
reporter with Bloomberg News over the
past couple of weeks some famous
investors have made some headlines with
their comments about the stock market
and quick spoiler alert they have not
been the most optimistic take Warren
Buffett for example known as the Oracle
of Omaha well at his company's annual
meeting in the beginning of May we found
out that during the sell-off he was
actually raising his cash file rather
than deploying it well typically during
a sell-off the idea is that Apple owes
their great deals you can find stops at
such great value that that is when you
want to put money to work so the saying
we all know is actions speak louder than
words so if Warren Buffett wasn't buying
stocks then why should other people have
been and he's not alone take investing
great Stan Druckenmiller for example
over the past couple of weeks he came
out and he said that the prospects for a
v-shaped recovery in the economy are
nothing but a quote unquote fantasy of
Egypt's recovery is exactly what it
sounds like say you were to chart GDP
gross domestic product for example if it
looked like a V that means you have fast
down and you also have fast on the way
up so what that looks like on a chart is
the letter of a V well he said it's a
fantasy and he also said that the risk
reward for stocks right now that he sees
is the worst of his lifetime
so quite the proclamation and they're
not alone we've heard from others coming
up to but meanwhile sucks the market has
remained resilient but to their point we
have started to see some fragility in
the markets take what happened with
moderna for example this past week on
Monday there were some great reports
about one of its vaccine trials for the
corona virus and we saw the
& p500 jumped over three percent well
the next day we had some reports that
are coming out that were a bit more
skeptical and we just saw it reversed we
saw stocks traverse as they were going
into the close of markets at 4:00 p.m.
and they ended the day down so
volatility is creeping back into markets
daily swings are now widening out
certainly it's all keeping us on our
toes governments all over the world are
cautiously reopening businesses and
public faces but experts warn the
coronavirus pandemics could continue in
waves lasting beyond the Year 2022
it's forethought on everyone's mind
right now
Florida is ready to take its first steps
toward reopening Texas is open for
business
South Carolina Oklahoma and Alaska also
slowly opening for business when will we
actually be ready to reopen I hit up my
colleague and friend John Lauer Minh to
ask more what's the big number how long
is this potentially going to last
according to the experts you've spoken
with yeah the idea is that the pandemic
point lasts for two years which is kind
of surprising considering that people
are already talking about reopening we
will need to go back to a very strict
regimen of lockdown unless we have a
vaccine if there's a vaccine then all
bets are off now we've got all this new
vaccine technology like the mRNA
technology from moderna that enables us
to develop exceeds extremely quickly in
a matter of month whether that's going
to be enough to vaccinate the entire
world that's anybody's guess and will we
experience any normalcy in those two
years
will it be locked down the entire time
if people continue to you know catch
this disease and die very quickly you
have to do something right
you can't ignore that and so the
measures that we have in the absence of
a vaccine are social distancing measures
by concern that if some areas
city-states or what-have-you
jump over those various checkpoints and
prematurely open up without having the
capability of being able to respond
effectively and efficiently my concern
is that we will start to see little
spikes that might turn into outbreaks
dr. Falchi said rather famously you know
we don't make the time go by
this makes the timeline right but in
many ways it the virus doesn't that make
the timeline the lawmakers and
politicians make the timeline and they
make good decisions I think a lot of
time is based on what they're sensing
from the population a lot of its based
on the economy things that can't be
predicted if your hospitals are
incapacitated by people didn't care for
kovat and you know you have to make some
decisions based on that as well on the
other hand if your hospitals aren't full
in a lot of hospitals aren't you know
then they may feel empowered to you know
to open
[Music]
during this global pandemic the world
the World Health Organization launches a
collaborative project to find a vaccine
and treatments the World Health
Organization warning young people
they're not invincible
the World Health Organization officially
announced that this is a global pandemic
instead it's found controversy where
President Trump does find fault in
handling the pandemic is the World
Health Organization you know right now
there they're literally a pipe organ
vagina that's the way of view he accused
the body of being too trusting of
China's assertions that it had the virus
under control they not only need to
answer to the needs of over 100 member
states but the whims and politics of the
countries and organizations that donate
the lion's share of their budget this is
the story of how the w-h-o tried to
please the world and ended up losing its
biggest backer the World Health
Organization was founded in 1948 by the
also newly formed United Nations
Czechoslovakia jugo-slavia Denmark
Greece Poland Hungary and many other
nations have benefited from whu-oh
headquartered in Geneva they were tasked
to mandate and coordinate health policy
initial vision for World Health
Organization was not only to make it an
important agency focusing on health
issues disease issues disease outbreaks
but to try to create a form of
international cooperation collaboration
that would bind the nations together and
in the coming decades the w-h-o has
taken on a dizzying amount of missions
from world-altering ones like the
eradication of smallpox and the
identification of HIV to awareness
campaigns like safe driving suicide
prevention and anti-smoking psays
well there are several main roles so one
is to what they call its normative role
which means it sets standards for
medical matters throughout the world and
it has an important role in providing
technical support to low and middle
income countries in order to tackle all
of those initiatives the w-h-o has
become an incredibly complex
organization there are six regional
offices around the world in Congo
Denmark America India Egypt and the
Philippines all of which report to the
headquarters in Geneva each of which has
its own motor functioning bureaucratic
staff and the like the balance of
authority between the regional offices
and the headquarters in Geneva it's
always been slightly problematic to not
get them all reading from the same page
when they have different regional
constituents and within those regional
constituencies are 150 country offices
in order to run all of those offices
requires a great deal of money
originally in the form of assessed
contributions or dues by the Member
States assessments were determined by
the overall GDP or economic strength of
that particular country and this
population with some formula worked out
and that formula worked for a while
member states paid their dues the w-h-o
provided guidance for health issues
around the world
but over the last three decades that
amount of money declined and is now only
about 20% of its overall budget today
the w-h-o is mostly funded by voluntary
contributions with the United States
being by far the highest paying
contributor followed by the organization
started by this guy if anything kills
over ten million people in the next few
decades its most likely to be a highly
infectious virus rather than a war and
when and where the w-h-o gets its money
from influences so much about what it
can do and
the gates foundation can stay through
our extra budgetary funding but like so
much invested in polio no one can tell
us not to do that and that has made
w-h-o a very unbalanced and complicated
organization that unbalanced of
complicated bureaucracy has consistently
been one of the World Health
Organization's biggest criticisms but
they've also been criticized for how
they've reacted to the past two major
epidemics before kovat 19 we've now seen
another outbreak of SARS and potentially
we've seen a cluster and transmission of
the SARS virus in 2003 was SARS the
w-h-o was criticized for overreacting to
the disease which only had 774 known
deaths but ended up costing East Asian
countries over 20 billion dollars in
lost GDP hotels tour agencies and travel
companies are reported to have suffered
huge losses during the outbreak that led
to an under reaction in the response to
the Ebola epidemic in West Africa in
2014 the big decision before them
whether to label this worst-ever Ebola
outbreak a quote public health emergency
of international concern it didn't get a
grip on the situation and it delayed in
calling this public health emergency of
international concern the head of the
World Health Organization Margaret Chan
where she has she had been dealing with
outbreaks like bird flu like stars
shouldn't she have been handling this
better and so it was a general mess
which led to many investigations
afterwards about the wh shows very slow
and inefficient and inadequate response
so with the overreaction to SARS and
under reaction to Ebola kovat 19 was a
chance for the w-h-o to finally get
things right and initially everyone
seemed happy with their performance
kovat 19 is a real threat it is a real
threat to everyone on the planet it took
the WHL one month to declare kovin 19 in
international health emergency compare
that to the four months it took them to
call Ebola in international health
emergency and Trump who originally
praised China and the wh OHS response to
the pandemic so far I think John has
been trying to be or at least they seem
to be trying to be somewhat transparent
with us he later turned on a dime
blaming not only China for the pandemic
but the w-h-o as well
the w-h-o willingly took China's
assurances to face value and they took
it just at face value and defended the
actions of the Chinese government even
praising China for its so-called
transparency I don't think so
this was partially a response to the
w-h-o director-general Tadros at Anan
Gabri a sis's constant praise of China
during the pandemic I will praise China
again and again because its actions
actually helped in reducing the spread
of coronavirus to other countries China
as well as critics of trumps
administration say trump shifted the
blame for domestic political reasons to
divert attention from his catastrophic
failure to address the crisis in america
whether it be from initially downplaying
the virus his big vast land of ours this
great country of ours move two hundred
and forty cases most of those people are
going to be fine to touting unproven
treatments a drug called
hydroxychloroquine and it's shown very
encouraging very very encouraging early
results I think it's gonna be I think
it's gonna be great all while the death
rate in America surpassed that of the
rest of the world and even though there
are accusations that China has not been
transparent about their numbers of kovat
nineteen Tadros and the w-h-o were
presented with an impossible decision
the w-h-o has no power of enforcement
they cannot dispatch a team against
their country's wishes they're dependent
on data coming out of that country with
a presumption that countries will
cooperate in no situation could the WHL
please both the US and China and that
resulted in Trump taking punitive
action today I'm instructing my
administration to halt funding of the
World Health Organization while a review
is conducted to assess mismanaging and
covering up the spread of the corona
virus and remember that chart for who
funds the w-h-o it's not just a huge
loss for the organization but for poorer
countries around the globe every one of
the essential functions of the WHL would
be immediately challenged and threatened
if not stopped and while America has the
CDC to create their own guidelines and
best practices countries and other parts
of the world don't have those resources
and are desperately dependent upon the
w-h-o to provide equipment information
interventions and now those will be
seriously challenged if not stopped
completely so where does this leave the
World Health Organization right now
apparently it's not up to them but us
reminded of a quote by Larry gostin who
was one of the international health
experts it was very important in the
whu-oh he has said the world has gotten
the w-h-o that it deserves the world has
created this organization with all its
false flaws inconsistencies and
efficiencies can the world wake up can
this crisis cost the world to say we
really do eat a well-functioning and
truly neutral world health body that
will not be beholden to various
financial interests political interest
and out of crisis can come a little
disaster but hope and a new beginning
will the world let it
all right that's the show for this week
thanks for watching but remember you can
find all of your current virus news from
quick-take 24/7 on Twitter Instagram
Facebook and of course YouTube and for a
daily recap of the day's top stories
subscribe to our newsletter thanks for
watching we'll see you next week
[Music]
you